[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présente le club des
territoires et avec nous aujourd'hui
Arnaud Benet rédacteur en chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire bonjour
AR merci d'être là Frédéric Dav bonjour
Frédéric merci également d'être avec
nous directeur général opinion de l'Ifop
on va par avec vous de la menace
terroriste qui inquiète les Français
après l'attaque d'arace comment répondre
à cette inquiétude une unité nationale
est-elle possible Quentin vous nous
détaillerai le sondage de Frédérique
rebonjouronjour à tous retour des
vendredis retour de qutin et on parlera
du sondage de Frédéric avec vous dans
quelques instants Quentin d'abord on
regarde ensemble l'actualité dans nos
[Musique]
régions l'actualité dans nos région avec
nos partenaires de la presse régionale
on va à Strasbourg on retrouve Olivier
Claudon bonjour Olivier merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous journalistes politique
aux Dernières Nouvelles d'Alsace dans
vos pages de sujets en plein cœur de
l'actualité Olivier d'abord ce festival
de musique sacrée à Strasbourg festival
qui vise à tisser des liens entre les
religions
oui c'est c'est un reportage de ma
consœur Catherine pitre qui est allé
écouter de la musique sacrée à la Grande
Mosquée de Strasbourg hier matin c'est
dans le cadre du festival de champ sacré
des sacrées journées qui se tient sur
une dizaine de jours hier matin ce
concert était destiné à de de jeunes
enfants des écoliers et des des
collégiens c'était un concert qui s'est
bien passé mais sous haute sécurité
alors le festival connaît quelques
petites tensions c'est sa 11e édition ça
a pas toujours été simple il essaie de
travailler le dialogue
interreligieux et il se trouve que le le
contexte d'aujourd'hui vient vient
rendre un peu plus complex encore ces
organisations de de de concerts croisés
de musique juive chrétienne musulmane
hindou bouddhiste dans des dans des
lieux de culte de façon indifférenciée
chrétiens juifs musulmans bouddhiste et
cetera euh il y a eu une première
annulation dimanche dernier dans dans
une mosquée du côté de mulouse et puis
le concert de clôture à la grande
synagogue de Strasbourg dimanche est
annulé et celui de dimanche matin à la
grande mosquée est annulé également
alors c'est en lien avec le contexte
géopolitique puisque il y a des tensions
les organisateurs expliquent que leur
festival repose à la fois sur le vivre
ensemble et sur la sécurité et ces deux
aspects sont rendus très complexes
aujourd'hui et Olivier Strasbourg
accueille également depuis hier le
séminaire de rentrée des sénateurs les
républicains
oui tout à fait alors vous allez me dire
c'est c'est un peu tard on est le 20
octobre pour un séminaire de rentrée
mais le le président du groupe LR au
Sénat Bruno retaillot avait souhaité
attendre endre le renouvellement partiel
du Sénat le le 25 septembre dernier pour
pouvoir intégrer à ce séminaire les les
nouveaux les nouveaux sénateur du groupe
LR et apparenté donc ils sont une
vingtaine et donc ce groupe ce groupe
tient son séminaire depuis hier et
jusqu'à ce soir à Strasbourg alors hier
ils se sont réunis au Parlement européen
qui tient sa session plainère cette
semaine donc le le groupe a travaillé
sur les questions européennes en
rencontrant Gabri Gabriel mezola la la
présidente du du Parlement européen
également Manfred Weber le président du
groupe PPE dans lequel siège la
délégation française des eurodéputés LR
et aujourd'hui le groupe va se retrouver
dans un un site en centrreeville de
Strasbourg pour travailler sur les
questions de de politique intérieur et
notamment préparer le le programme
législatif à venir Bruno retaillot va va
préparer ses troupes et travailler avec
elle sur le évidemment le le le
rendez-vous législatif important qui
arrive le projet de loi
immigration Bruno retaillot explique que
le groupe sera intraitable et souhaite
considérablement durcir je le cite ce
texte merci Olivier merci beaucoup on
regarde la Une des Dernières Nouvelles
d'Alsace la France pleure Dominique
Bernard c'est à la Une de votre journal
ce matin merci Olivier d'avoir été avec
nous on va parler justement des
républicains et de la loi immigration
dans quelques instants mais d'abord on
va parler de la menace terroriste qui
inquiète les Français Quentin c'est une
étude de Frédéric une étude de l'OPE
quels sont les enseignements
effectivement on a lu votre sondage paru
hier Frédéric effectivement c'est assez
logique dans le contexte actuel mais les
Français sont inquiets vous l'avez
chiffré à la question comment
évaluez-vous la menace terroriste dans
notre pays aujourd'hui et bien 90 % des
Français interrogés jugent la menace
élevée précisément 44 % la juge très
élevé 46 % plutôt élevé ces chiffres
sont en haut ces derniers jours quand
voilà avant les attaques du Hamas sur
Israël et et l'assassinat de Dominique
Bernard 76 % des Français jugé cette
menace élevée c'est donc plus 14 points
en quelques jours avec une forte
progression de la part des Français qui
jugent la menace très élevée elle passe
de 15 à 44 % en quelques jours mais il
faut dire que nous sommes sur un plateau
haut si vous me permettez l'expression
depuis 2015 avec des taux parfois même
au-dessus de 95 % il y avait eu une
légère acalmie de cette inquiétude
pendant le confinement mais l'assassinat
de Samuel pti avait à nouveau tendu la
situation en France puis une nouvelle
baisse une nouvelle accalmie et le
sentiment d'un risque sécuritaire est
reparti à la hausse depuis 13 jours à ce
propos écoutez géralde Darman lors des
la séance des questions au Gouvernement
c'était mercredi au Sénat sur ce risque
précis d'attentat
écouter mais la menace principale vous
le savez c'est une menace endogène une
ubérisation pardon de ce mot du
terrorisme qui attend la publication des
caricatures des soi-disants blasphèmes
des soi-disant difficultés euh qui
toucheraient le monde particulier pour
lequel ils seraient attachés dans leur
fantasmogorie des complots sur Internet
qui peut-être permet de passer à l'acte
parce qu'un diodisme d'atmosphère existe
du fait malheureusement d'un écosystème
islamiste que nous devons combattre et
c'est pour ça que le gouvernement par la
loi séparatisme par les lois terrorisme
par le courage de service de
renseignement au combat voilà pour les
grands enseignements de cette étudiep
judiciale pours radio et Frédéric on va
en parler avec vous Frédéric Quentin a
donné le chiffre la menace terroriste
est très élevée l'inquiétude est viv
chez les Français oui c'est vrai Quentin
l'a très bien dit c'est une question
qu'on pose depuis le 11 septembre 2001
donc ça fait très longtemps il y a une
vraie historicité et depuis 2015 depuis
Charlie Hebdo et le 13 novembre jamais
la menace n'a véritablement disparu dans
notre enqu dans notre enquête de rentrée
sur les grands enjeux pour la rentrée FO
féucial pour su radio alors qu'il n'y
avait eu heureusement que très peu
d'attentats ces derniers temps la menace
terroriste était dans le top 8 ou top 9
des enjeux prioritaires pour les
Français là ce qui est très
impressionnant c'est le taux c'est le
score sur la menace très élevée 44 % 29
points de plus depuis novembre 2 22 ça
touche toutes les catégories hein c'est
un enjeu maintenant très homogène il y a
pas comme par le passé des des
sympathisants de droite plus inquiet que
ce de gauche ça c'est vraiment
complètement diffusé à l'ensemble de la
population dans votre enquête vous nous
avez fourni effectivement la liste même
des catégories sociau professionnelles
la liste aussi par âge la liste aussi
par appartenance ou sentiment
d'appartenance à une famille politique
on a cherché quelle famille se
démarquait en fait on n pas on n' pas
noté le détail de de de cette partie de
l'enquête parce que en fait ça touche
tout le monde voilà et au cœur de cette
montée forte faite par rapport à l'année
dernière je pense qu'il y a deux choses
il y a une sorte de loi d'opinion qui a
complètement changé par le par le passé
ce qui se passait à l'échelle euh
internationale n'intéressait que
modérément les Français et des
catégories précises les personnes
diplômées les personnes âgées les
personnes très informées maintenant
l'international intéresse tout le temps
parce que les Français se disent ce qui
se passe en Syrie ce qui peut se passer
lors d'une crise climatique peut avoir
des conséquences direct chez nous et là
plus précisément après l'attaque
terroriste du Hamas c'était une enquête
F fiduciale également pour SUD RADIO un
chiffre m'avait frappé 3/4 des Français
considérai que ce conflit allait avoir
des répercussions importantes sur la
société française ce n'est pas une
surprise mais c'est intéressant de
l'objectiver à un niveau aussi élevé al
non oui alors c'est pas une surprise en
effet il y a un effet de contexte qui
pèse forcément sur les perceptions des
Français il y a malheureusement le
tragique assassinat d'un enseignant à à
ras il y a aussi j'allais dire le
discours gouvernemental qui quand même
est un discours qui de fait pointe la
menace et considère que la menace est
trèsord donc donc tous ces paramètres ne
peuvent que renforcer une opinion
publique qui aujourd'hui est inquiète et
qui se sent menacé moi ce qui me frappe
dans ce sondage en eff et c'est je
rejoins ce que vient de dire Frédéric
c'est disons la dimension très homogène
de la réaction toute catégorie
socio-pressionnel confondu et surtout
j'allais dire toute affiliation ou toute
sympathie partisane confondue alors
c'est vrai que c'est un peu plus faible
lorsque l'on regarde du côté par exemple
de la France insoumise mais quand même
une très large majorité des
sympathisants de la France insoumise eux
aussi sont aujourd'hui particulièrement
inquiets donc ce contexte d'une certaine
façon n'est pas surprenant bon la
réalité c'est que aujourd'hui l'exécutif
est confronté un vrai sujet et un
véritable enjeu dans un contexte en plus
social et économique qui quand même
n'est pas simple ouais c'est ça et
est-ce qu'il y a le sentiment chez les
Français d'une impuissance de l'État
face à cette menace terroriste alors
dans l'histoire de ce baromètre dans
l'histoire des attentats il y a eu un
avant et après Nice en 2015 unité union
très forte des Français autour de
François Hollande de Manuel Vals avec
des taux de confiance dans le couple
exécutif qui avait été très fort 2016
Nice Saint-Étienne rouvrai faut pas en
fait l'oublier après le 14 juillet le 14
juillet je crois que c'était le 18 ou le
19 juillet on a une opinion qui se
retourne et à partir de là
systématiquement il y a un crédit
minoritaire qui n'est pas nul hein qui d
qui est autour de 40 % de mémoire de
l'opinion publique sur le couple Holland
Vals puis après Emmanuel Macron pour
faire face au terrorisme parce que le
terrorisme devient comment dire euh
récurrent parce que depuis le 13
novembre on voit que il y a un double
mouvement depuis le le 13 novembre on
voit que tout le monde peut-être euh
fait peut-être touché des personnes sur
des euh terrasses un prêtre euh la des
zones extrêmement rurales autour de de
Carcassonne après il y a quelques années
et puis maintenant aussi c'est un
phénomène qui est pas antagoniste les
Français ont conscience qu'il y a des
segments de population qui constituent
des cibles pour les terroristes les
Français de confession ou de culture
juive c'était l'enquête il obj d'aider
de dimanche dernier où on avait un
Français sur deux qui qui considérait
que leur que leurs compatriotes de
confession ou de culture juiv avait plus
de risque de subir un attentat
terroriste en février 2016 ce chiffre
n'était que de 15 % les Français de
confession Juifs les policiers et
désormais suite au drame de Dominique
Bernard les enseignants n'oublions pas
que Samuel paatti a été assassiné pour
ce qu'il avait fait il n'avait rien fait
de mal bien sûr mais pour ce qu'il avait
fait là la phrase de la saillence c'est
trouvez-moi un professeur d'histoire
c'est parce que prof parce que il est
prof juste il a été assassiné pour ce
qu'il avait enseigné donc c'est pas
seulement pour ce qu'il avait fait c'est
pour ce qu'il avait enseigner c'est
extrêmement important de de le dire et
de le préciser parce que c'était sa
mission en effet qu'il remplissait et en
plus savec qu'on l' on l'a on l'a
constaté parfois un soutien pour le
moins aussillant de sa hiérarchie non
moi si vous voulez ce qui je crois est
important c'est que je ne sais pas
aujourd'hui quel est l'état de l'opinion
publique en terme j'allais dire de
d'appel à l'unité je n'ai pas vu en tout
cas d'études moi sur ce sujet mais ce
qui me frappe en tout cas par rapport à
la séquence qu'on a connu en 2015-26
avec les attentats de Charlie contre
Charlie Hebdo du Bataclan et puis
ensuite en juillet 2016 de Nice c'est
que à ce moment-là on avait quand même
globalement une une scène politique une
classe politique qui réagissait de
manière assez homogène c'est-à-dire
faisait corps avec le le avec l'exécutif
faisait corps j'allais dire avec la
nation dans sa dans sa condamnation et
dans son indignation là forcé de le
constat constater c'est que avec ce que
nous venons de traverser nous avons
manifestement des voix qui sont des
voies discordantes et des voies
dissonnantes ce qui ne manque pas
d'ailleurs de poser des problèmes à
gauche donc ça c'est un premier point
alors il y a peut-être un facteur
explicatif à cette désunion de la de la
de la scène politique nationale c'est
que 2015-216 l'ennemi c'était
daesh là si vous voulez on a à mon avis
une nuance à apporter c'est que
évidemment le Hamas est un mouvement
terroriste évidemment
le Hamas est un mouvement islamiste mais
le Hamas surf sur la cause palestinienne
ce qui est un autre enjeu politique
aussi dans l'agenda politique à gauche
qui explique vraisemblablement aussi
peut-être que on n pas ce phénomène
d'unité au niveau des forces politique
que l'on a connu par le passé on va en
parler justement de de la question de la
gauche Quentin oui vous vous parlez de
de Samuel paatti effectivement de de ce
qui s'est passé à ras la semaine
dernière il y avait Michel paaty qui
était au
mardi qui est la sœur de de l'enseignant
assassiné il y a 3 ans et c une audition
extrêmement solennelle extrêmement
émouvante et pendant cette audition on a
évoqué des chiffres des signaux qui sont
pas très encourageants pour les
professeurs il y en a un sur deux selon
un sondage qui évite certains sujets et
qui s'autocenture dans une C
effectivement une une étude de de de
l'Ifop qui s'autocensure sur sur
certains sujets et ce chiffre vous me
corrigez si je me trompe mais il est en
en évolution par rapport à des données
de
2018ug 2018 non mais vous avez tout à
fait raison de faire rappeler ça c'est
une enquête Ifop fait pour le knal le
Comité national d'action qui avait été
présenté en juin à Montpellier où il y a
un maire Michel de la fusse qui est un
ardent défenseur de la question laïque
non j'avais été frappé par un autre
chiffre extrêmement fort où 4
enseignants sur 10 42 % considérait
qu'ils avaient
modifié en profondeur leur manière
d'enseigner depuis la assassinat de
Samuel pati et ce 42 était majoritaire
chez les enseignants les plus jeunes et
chez ceux enseignants en en ancienne ZEP
en réseau d'éducation prioritaire il
faut pas négliger à quel point
l'assassinat de Samel pati a été un
traumatisme pour les Français dans nos
enquêtes qualitatives quand on demande
aux Français spontanément de raconter
l'histoire du pays depuis 5 ans 10 ans
l'affaire paâtissort systématiquement et
pour le corps enseignant et c'est dire
que la réactivation de ce traumatisme
par l'horrible assassinat de Dominique
Bernard et ben crée un choc encore dans
la communauté éducative ce qui change
c'est qu'il y a un crédit de confiance
très fort des Français et du corps
enseignant à l'égard du ministre Gabriel
l'attaque de Dominique Bernard elle a
été commise par un assaillant qui est
arrivé sur le sol français très jeune
qui s'est ensuite radicalisé est-ce que
les Français attendent du gouvernement
des mesures plus fermes sur ce sujet sur
la question migratoire c'est absolument
évident dans une enquête du mois de
septembre donc qui ne portait pas sur ce
cas il y avait 89 % des Français qui
souhaitaient que les délinquants
étrangers soit expulsés à l'issue de
leur peine de fa prison il y a une
demande de reprise en main de l'État le
souvenir de l'Aquarius à Marseille où
200 migrants disparaissent ses vapor du
jour au lendemain ça agace les Français
avec l'idée que l'État n'est pas mettre
chez lui pour autant sur la question
fait les Français ne sont pas que d'un
seul bloc quand nous quand nous testons
le projet de régulariser les sans papier
travaillant dans des métiers en en
tension 2/ers des Français se disent
favorabl quand nous soumettons la
fameuse phrase que nous posons depuis
des années avec la Fondation Jean joress
c'est le devoir de la France
d'accueillir des personnes des réfugiés
fillant la guerre ou la misère on trouve
une majorité de Français mais sur la
question des délinquants sur la question
de la de la maîtrise migratoire de
l'immigration choisie là on a une
opinion très unanime et qui est en
attente de fermeté oui la tendance la
tendance de fond est quand même à une
demande de fermeté et d'autorité sur la
question migratoire très très nettement
quand on compare à d'autres je veux dire
séquences de la vie politique française
ça je crois que c'est un point tout à
fait essentiel et il faut le rappeler
après l'autre question qu'il faut se
poser c'est de savoir si euh les
Français jugent que l'action de
l'exécutif est en soi efficace et
efficiente ou en tout cas même ces
propositions d'action à venir suffiront
à calmer les inquiétudes des Français
c'est là que géralin il brandit son
projet de loi immigration ça va changer
la nature des débat il y a d'autres il y
a d'autres études d'opinion alors c'est
pasipope là en l'occurrence mais qui
montrre que une majorité de Français est
très dubitative c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire quant à la position de
fermeté de l'exécutif et quant même au
texte de loi qui doit arriver bientôt en
discussion au Sénat donc de ce point de
vue l'exécutif fait un gros effort à
faire pour essayer de convaincre les
Français à la fois du bien fondé de son
action actuelle et du bien fondé de son
action à venir je crois que ça c'est un
vrai sujet qui se pose et d'ailleurs on
en parlera peut-être tout à l'heure
c'est une question qui se pose aussi du
côté des républicains ben oui justement
on va en parler parce que effectivement
il y a l'exécutif mais il y a aussi les
républicains est-ce que ça va changer la
nature des débats est-ce que le contexte
actuel va rendre compliqué pour les
républicains le fait de mettre des
lignes rouges des conditions au vot tout
dépendra de la réponse de l'exécutif
notamment un certain nombre de demandes
des républicains qui ont fait depuis
maintenant quelques mois état des
mesures qu'il souhaite mettre en place
dans le cadre de ce projet de loi le
Sénat en mars la commission des Lois du
Sénat je crois en mars de cette année a
largement revu le texte du gouvernement
alors j'ai cru comprendre que le
ministre de l'intérieur était prêt lui à
bouger sur un certain nombre des
propositions des républicains et de la
majorité sénate Royal euh la question
qui se pose aussi quand même sur le fond
pour la majorité euh présidentielle
relative à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
que si vous voulez mais ça on l'a vu
depuis très longtemps c'est que c'est un
sujet qui à l'intérieur quand même de
cette majorité entraîne des lignes de
clivage donc si vous voulez il y a un
jeu d'équilibre c'est compliqué à
réaliser et à opérer pour le ministre de
l'Intérieur encore une fois dans un
contexte qui est celui d'une majorité
très relative à l'Assemblée nationale
oui et là on est en vraie rupture avec
la loi immigration de Gérard Colomb en
2018 où là il y avait au contraire un
avantage pour la majorité d'êreessente
puisqu'elle était une sorte de point
d'équilibre entre une gauche qui la
jugeait trop Durre et une droite trop
l'xis là on a cette demande de fermeté
très forte il y a le rôle des répu
rublain qui est absolument central
vont-ils voter avec le gouvernement il y
a aussi un enjeu pour eux parti de
gouvernement ne vont-ils pas devoir
intégrer le bloc le bloc central face au
bloc nups et au bloc RN et justement on
va parler de laanupes puisque cette
semaine a vu la gauche tangué après les
propos de la direction de la France
insoumise refusant de qualifier le Hamas
de terroriste l'anupe s fracturé les
communistes dénonce une impasse le PS a
suspendu sa participation et certains
socialistes voudraient aller encore plus
loin image de Patrick hanner le patron
des sénateurs PS qui était notre invité
Monsieur Mélenchon ça suffit il faut
vraiment tout remettre à plat et
reconstruire une autre union je
considère que la nupè qui a été un
accord électoral qui est devenu
progressivement un outil au service de
Monsieur Mélenchon pour ses ambitions
gouvernementales et on sait que ses
ambitions et bien sont quand même
limitées parce qu'il est dans la
protestation et dans la logique du Grand
Soir et bien cette nupesse aujourd'hui
pour moi est une impasse politique c'est
une impasse politique aujourd'hui l'ANUP
Arnaud pour vous ben l'ANUP c'était un
cartel électoral ça a été rappelé par
Monsieur caner mais le le problème c'est
que si vous voulez je dire dès le début
dès sa gestation il y avait beaucoup
d'ambivalence et d'ambiguité qui
présidaient à ce cartel électoral sur la
question de la laïcité sur la question
du nucléaire entre autres donc alors à
la faveur si je puis dire de ce qui se
passe
aujourd'hui au Moyen-Orient on a
clairement une réactivation de des
divisions et de manière très violente je
ne vois pas à ce stade comment
finalement cet espace politique qu'avait
su créer Jean-Luc Mélenchon au moment
des législatives peut perdurer très
longtemps on voit que beaucoup sont en
train de prendre leur distance le Parti
communiste une partie des socialistes
que de toute façon dans la perspective
des prochaines élections européennes il
n'y aura pas de liste commune donc
manifestement je crois qu'on est quand
même rentré dans une autre sé politique
à gauche et surtout si vous voulez les
positions de ces derniers jours de la
plupart des dirigeants de la France
insoumise à l'exception peut-être de
Monsieur Ruffin et de Monsieur Corbière
rendent très difficile la pérenité de ce
cartel électoral oui d'ailleurs dès le
début les Français avaient intériorisé
que ce n'était qu'un cartel électoral et
rien de plus c'était une enquête hiop
humanité de dès septembre 2022 là ce qui
est vrai ce qui change quand même c'est
que les voies discordantes remettant en
cause Jean-Luc Mélenchon viennent de LFI
lui-même ce qu'a dit Ruffin Alexis
Corbière Raquel garidau qui a parlé de
moi en fait gâché
DEP également
clétin et puis il y a aussi ce que nous
disent dans nos enquêtes le peuple de
gauche pour parler comme le faisait
François mitteran quand on regarde toute
une série de sujets la police tu il y a
un racisme systémique la BAA une
majorité de sympathis disant LFI je le
rappelle soutenait l'interdiction prise
par Gabriel hatal
traité traité Rousell de de d'Orio et là
bien sûr ce qui s'est passé ce refus de
qualifier le Hamas de groupe terroristes
il y a un décalage de plus en plus
profond entre ce que nous disent les
sympathisants de gauche et les
prisespposition de la France insoumise
ça devient intenable comme le dit Arnaud
une liste unique pour les élection
européenne est maintenant complètement
utopique dans l'enquête publiée hier
avec Figaro et SUD RADIO avanthier
pardon on n bien sûr pas testé
l'hypothèse de nissoni comme on le
faisait encore au mois de juin ou au
mois de mai et très clairement pour une
majorité de sympathisants de gauche 60 %
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est jugé comme un
handicap pour LFI pour la nupes et pour
le but de final faire gagner la gauche
en 2027 donc on est vraiment peut-être
au bout de ce processus pour être tout à
fait complet Patrick canner non mais
pour être tout à fait précis Patrick
canner il était opposé à l'accord
électoral de laanup dès le départ dès
2022 on avait vu Carole Delga Bernard
cas a pris Paro très fort ce qui n'it
pas été le cas de même ce qu' dit
Olivier fort extrêmement r au sein du
Parti socialiste il y avait une tendance
qui s'était réunie autour de Nicolas
Mayer rinol pour dire que c'était pas la
stratégie adoptée la bonne stratégie
adoptée pendant le congrès du parti
socialist av déjà failli créer un
schisme au sein du PS l'hiver dernier
cette question la stratégie à gauche
donc on voit que c'est en fait la
résultante d'une année de crise même au
SE du clairement c'est la gauche que
l'on pourrait qualifier de territoriale
celle qui est implantée dans les
territoires la gauche j'allais dire des
notables d'une certaine façon qui
aujourd'hui et qui dès le début a mis
j'allais dire en j'ais dire s'est
interrogé sur la pertinence de cet
accord électoral et aujourd'hui
manifestement les événements sont en
train de leur donner raison un dernier
mot non c'est vrai que la gauche est à
la croisée des chemins on a des
sympathisant gauche qui refusent
maintenant la main m de Jean-Luc
bélenchon qui ne se projette pas dans
une nupes comme un avenir désirable pour
gagner les prochaines échéances
électorales il y a clairement un espace
d'une gauche de gouvernement la question
c'est qui peut l'incarner est-ce que
c'est l'ancien président françoisand
est-ce que c'est Carol Delga qui a été
très critique comme vous le dites
Quentin dès le début avis de cet accord
de la nupes mais pour l'instant c'est
vrai que l'équation que font toujours
les Français nupes égal LFI lfgal
Mélenchon laanupes reste Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais pour la première fois je
le répète il est vivement contesté par
ses propres troupes on verra la suite
évidemment allez c'est vendredi Arnaud
vous le savez le vendredi on vous emmène
découvrir notre patrimoine mathas sis
nous emmène à Lyon ville lumière il y a
bientôt 130 ans le cinématographe était
inventé à Lyon les frères Lumières
mettaient alors au point un procédé qui
allait révolutionner la planète depuis
maintenant 15 ans le festival Lumière
tente de raviver cette mémoire dans le
berceau du
cinéma tout a commencé par la lumière de
lumières même Auguste et Louis deux
frères l'un physicien l'autre biologiste
qui apportent leur touche finale à une
série d'inventions pour aboutir au
cinématographe c'est là qu' qu' a
vraiment débuté le cinéma les premières
images de de de film les frères lumièr
les ont les les ont pris d'en face juste
voilà euh c'est la place du premier
cinématographe parce que ils avaient
installé leur caméras là et ils
demandaient à leurs ouvriers de sortir
ou les voilà au moment de la sortie des
usines le procédé révolutionnaire se
répand comme une traînée de poudre dans
le monde entier mais en bientôt 130 ans
sa ville d'origine Lyon n'en a que trop
peu récolté les lauriers on retient
souvent la la la première séance de
cinéma au au au Grand Café le 28
décembre
1895 comme date de naissance du cinéma
alors c'est vrai que c'est la date de de
naissance de de la salle de cinéma ça a
un peu occulté peut-être le le
travail disons précédent qui avait été
fait autour des premiers films de de de
des fres lumière mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui quand même on on sait que
que que tout a démarré à Lyon alors en
2009 le Lyonnais thry fremau directeur
de l'Institut Lumière décide de lancer
un festival pas tout à fait comme les
autres je crois que ce festival j'ai la
j'ai le privilège et la chance de
diriger le festival de Cann et il est
vrai que le festival Lumière est on est
un peu le le le le pas l'opposé pas le
contraire mais le complément can c'est
le cinéma très contemporain ici c'est le
cinéma dans son histoire sauf que ce
festival c'est comme lorsqu'on fait une
avant-première nous on fait des
avant-premières de copies restauré de
film ancien lui l'homme fort du cinéma
français veut rendre à sa ville un peu
de son histoire en conjuguant le passé
au présent placer le cinéma au cœur de
la ville comme ça pendant pendant plus
d'une semaine
euh ramener la mémoire du cinématographe
Lumière au contemporain accueillir des
metteurs en
scène venu du monde entier qui découvre
pour certains certains autres le savent
qu'il y a une rue du premier film dans
le monde et voir la ferveur du public
dans l'accueil qu'il qu'il leur font
qu'il leur fait euh le le cinéma est
l'une des choses les plus importantes de
cette ville le festival Lumière le bien
nommé n'est ni une compétition ni une
foire à la promotion mais un rendez-vous
d'amateurs de toile et de salles
obscures pour certains chauvins c'est
vrai que c'est un petit peu l'événement
qui qui prône ce cette création
lyonnaise du du cinéma une petite phrase
de Louis Lumière qui disait que voilà la
la fierté d'avoir inventé le
cinématographe c'est que ça fait plaisir
à tout le monde et lui c'était la plus
belle chose qui pouvait lui arriver et
c'est vrai que le cinéma c'est c'est
incroyable quand on peut s'évader en
l'espace d'une heure ou ou même moins et
je suis heureux qu'ils ai qu'ils aient
fait ce ce festival quoi voilà il a fu
des personnalités comme ptranavnier tout
ça pour que le cinéma revienne chez nous
il prennent la place qu'il méritait quoi
depuis bientôt 15 ans maintenant chaque
année les plus grands du cinéma visitent
la capitale des Gaules à l'image de West
Anderson l'un des réalisateurs les plus
talentueux de sa
génération et à présent aucun Cinéfil
n'ignore où se trouve la ville des
lumières et voilà pour ce reportage de
Mathias SZ alle est comme tous les jours
on regarde ce qu'elle a une de vos
quotidiens
[Musique]
réun et Quentin la presse régionale
revient ce matin sur les obsèes de
l'enseignant Dominique Bernard qui se
tenait hier à aras voilà les journaux
reviennent sur cet hommage poignant pr
en présence du ministre de l'éducation
nationale Gabriel Atal et du président
de la République toute la nation toucher
au cœur liton ainsi à la Une de l'Alsace
ce sont les mots de l'évêque d'aras à
l'autre bout de la France dans le
mililibre à Montpellier et la même idée
l'adieu au discret héros même une dans
la voie du Nord et Ouest France dans la
voie du Nord on lit la dignité et
l'amour malgré la douleur dans ces
journaux on lit le portrait du
professeur de lettrre qui aimait ses
élèves qui aimait la littérature le
cinéma on en parlait il un instant
l'Italie et sa femme écrit l'Alsace par
exemple dans le même journal ses mots
les textes choisis pour son enterrement
les messages lus par la famille et les
collègues de Dominique Bernard disent la
souffrance vertigineuse de la perte mais
aussi l'amour et le besoin de retrouver
de l'espoir la montagne revient sur le
risque sécuritaire voilà on en parlait
il y a un instant sur ce plateau on le
voit à la une de la montagne la France
sur ses gardes titre ainsi le journal de
ClermontFerrand déjà une semaine que le
plan végippirate a été placé à son degré
maximum urgence attentat avec par
exemple une montée en puissance du
dispositif Sentinel en auverne ronalp
les effectifs sont ainsi passés de 3500
à 7000 militaires et patrouilles ont été
intensifié la présence des militaires a
un coût pour les finances publicqu mais
leur capacité d'intervention se double
d'une visibilité très forte qui permet
de dissuader et de rassurer les
populations liton ainsi dans la montagne
ce matin les Aes maritimes en alerte
rouge météo oui regardez ni ce matin
aujourd'hui c'est en raison des fortes
pluies attendu depuis ce matin très tôt
une pensée pour tous les habitants du
département la préfecture appelle à
reporter tous les déplacements à pied ou
en voiture à ne pas descendre dans les
sous-sols ou les parkings l'ensemble des
établissements scolaires du 06 sont
fermés tout comme les établissements
publics et les parcs dans de nombreux
esprits hein des habitants il y a la
tempête Alex qui avait ravagé plusieurs
vallées c'était en 2020 on s'en souvient
allez on termine avec la touche du
vendredi Quentin trans jacqu Vabre voilà
et puis un peu d'air aussi dans cette
actualité effectivement où on suffoque
un peu mais effectivement c'est parti
liton à la Une de parisnormandie dans
son édition du Havre Jacques vre c'est
pour rappel tous les 2 ans deux marins
pas d'escal pas d'assistance le départ
se fait du Havre où les bateaux sont
arrivés le public est invité àer
rencontrer à rencontrer les skippers et
à partir de d'aujourd'hui le grand
départ c'est dans 9 jours pour une
arrivée prévue en Martinique le 12
novembre et pour finir je voulais vous
montrer des images qui ont été tourné il
y a 2 ans voilà c'est une aventure
humaine folle et puis ça donne toujours
des images absolument
fantastiques de la mer et de l'océan
puis effectivement ça nous sort de cette
actualité grand bolder merci Quentin
pour cette revue de presse Arnaud la une
de la revue politique et parlementaire
le savant le politique et le peuple
l'enjeu du siècle avec la contribution
de frédri excellent texte de Frédéri
voilà le RN en 2023 entre normalisation
et non banalisation Frédérique voilà
comme ça ça fait le lien entre vous deux
merci merci à tous les deux merci
Quentin merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
pour voir revoir cette émission c'est
sur publsenat.fr et nous on se retrouve
lundi on vous souhaite un très bon
weekend
[Musique]